يقول بيان صادر عن قصر باكنغهام للتو
إن أطباء الملكة قلقون
وأن هذه هي الكلمة التي يستخدمونها للقلق
بشأن صحتها وأوصوا بأن
تظل تحت الإشراف الطبي في
قلعة بالمورال ، فلنبدأ في التواصل مع ماكس
فوستر الموجود في لندن.
في تلك اللغة ،
لست متأكدًا من أننا رأينا شيئًا
كهذا تمامًا قبل أن
تسمع أنه لغة صارخة تمامًا ، يجب
أن أقول جون أنك محق في الإشارة
بالإضافة إلى أنني أتحدث إلى
مصدر يقول إن أفراد الأسرة المباشرين
قد تم إبلاغهم ،
لذا فهذه لغة تنذر بالسوء ، من
الواضح أننا رأينا الملكة في الأماكن
العامة مؤخرًا مع بعض اللقطات التي
تعينها لرئيس الوزراء الجديد
ليز تراست الآن الليلة الماضية كان من المفترض
أن يكون هناك لقاء سريع أه  من المجلس الخاص
الذي تشرف عليه الملكة
وكان من المقرر أن تحلف ليز ترست أم تقسم
اليمين لتصبح عضوًا في ذلك
المجلس الخاص وهي هيئة دستورية جوهرية
مركزية حقًا  لقد
صُدم الدستور البريطاني لدرجة أنها
لم تكن قادرة على أن تقسم رئيس
الوزراء على ذلك ، ولكن على وجه الخصوص عندما
كان اجتماعًا مكثفًا من بالمورال ،
لم تكن قادرة على القيام بذلك ، وقيل لنا
إن ذلك لأنها بذلت جهدًا مفرطًا.
هي نفسها بشكل فعال مع لقاءاتها
مع ليز تروس ومع رئيس الوزراء المنتهية ولايته
بوريس جونسون والآن
نتلقى هذا البيان
أه أن أه الأطباء قلقون أه
على صحتها وأوصوها
بالبقاء تحت إشراف طبي
فهي لا تزال مرتاحة على الرغم من أننا
أخبرنا في بالمورال
أوم أنهم لن يقدموا لنا أي
تحديثات حتى تكون هناك تحديثات يجب
متابعتها ، لكننا نعلم
بشكل فعال أنه
تم إخبارنا بأنك على أهبة الاستعداد للحصول على
التحديثات ، لذلك تم إبلاغ العائلة على
الأرجح بأنهم سيتجهون نحو
Balmoral